alguna vez has sentido que te esfuerzas
por aprender algo y simplemente no
puedes es te puede hacer pensar que no
eres tan inteligente verdad pues no es
tu culpa ni la de tu maestro simplemente
es la forma tradicional de aprendizaje
durante nuestro proceso escolar vamos
acumulando huecos aún no termina de
comprender pre álgebra y ya pasaste a
álgebra para cuando llegas a cálculo
tienes muchos huecos acumulados si hay
muchos huecos comprender cálculo puede
sentirse como una tarea imposible eso es
muy frustrante pero qué pasa si una
forma diferente de aprenderlo eso es el
aprendizaje de dominio a diferencia de
los procesos tradicionales de
aprendizaje en el cual todos los alumnos
se aprenden en fila india con el
aprendizaje a base de dominio vas a tu
propio paso avanzas a partir de
preguntas que están a tu nivel si
obtienes el 50% bien en el primer
intento no hay problema intenta cuantas
veces sea necesario obtener
retroalimentación conforme aprendes y
ayuda cuando las requieras los maestros
pueden monitorear tu progreso
identificar los huecos
dar que atención personalizada hay
décadas de estudios que demuestran que
el aprendizaje a través de dominio
funciona ahora tienes las herramientas
para hacerlo posible estás listo para
aprender lo que sea